Good evening.
I'm Homi Bhabha.
And it's my great
pleasure to welcome you
to this fascinating
event on origin stories.
And my thanks to our
remarkable group of speakers.
Stephen Greenblatt is John
Cogan University Professor
of the Humanities at Harvard.
His most recent book is The
Rise and Fall of Adam and Eve.
His previous book, The
Swerve, won the Pulitzer Prize
in 2012 and the 2011 National
Book Award for Nonfiction.
Kimberley Patton is Professor of
the Comparative and Historical
Study of Religion at the
Harvard Divinity School.
She specializes in ancient
Greek religion and archaeology
with research interests
in archaic sanctuaries
and the iconography
of sacrifice.
Her most recent book is
Religion of the Gods--
Ritual Paradox and Reflexivity.
Meredith Reiches-- did I get it?
Beautifully done.
All right, Meredith is Assistant
Professor of Anthropology
at UMass, Boston.
In her interdisciplinary
work on adolescence,
she seeks to tease out
the narrative elements
in the acts of conducting
and communicating science
and to analyze the side-by-side
with literary narratives
of coming of age,
asking the question,
what does it take to make
the transition from childhood
to adulthood in human society.
Richard Wrangham is
Ruth B. Moore Professor
of Biological
Anthropology at Harvard
and founder of the
Kibale Chimpanzee Project
Did I say that right?
[INAUDIBLE]
He's best known for his work on
the evolution of human warfare,
described in the
book, Demonic Males.
And on the role of cooking
in human evolution, described
in the book, Catching Fire--
How Cooking Made Us Human.
Amongst the many wonders of
Stephen Greenblatt's new book
is the belated invitation we
receive to the garden party.
After being expelled
from paradise
at the very start of the
story, the epilogue finally
lays on the garden party at
Uganda's Kibale National Park
in the company of
the chimpanzees.
And here in the Ugandan
research station,
at a great distance from
Harvard's heart of darkness,
for a brief fleeting
moment, time stands still.
And Stephen experiences a
kind of a hedonic tranquility.
Let me quote him.
"This then I thought is what
Paradise must have been--
no permanent address, no
planting and cultivating,
and, at that dizzying
height, the chimps
are up in their nests,
no predators and no fear.
I had glimpsed a part
of that ancient dream
of every tree of the garden--
thou mayest freely eat.
A paradisal moments,
originary and mythic,
so compelling to our sense
of identity and belonging,
our ancestry and its tradition,
because they are naturally
and historically
vicarious and voyeuristic.
If hell is other
people, Paradise is also
other people or other places."
Reading Stephen left me
with a stray thought.
Are myths of origin less
about the primal moment
of being or becoming and
more about constructing
a narrative about
recovery or rediscovering
the self, the legitimation
for a cultural and political
self-fashioning?
The political
identification with myths
of origins in our
times, at least,
have an unnervingly atavistic
and iterative address.
The fundamentalist return
to the unchanging reality
of Hindu scriptures, fables,
and myths of origin in India
today are formulated as the
recovery of a pure Hindutva
identity in the face of a
predatory secular modernity
and what they see as an
expanding Islamic hegemony.
I think you could make
this argument for many
of the revivals of
origin myths now.
They are the recovery
of a self in the face
of some kind of pursuit
or some kind of predation.
When we ask
ourselves, who are we,
why are we here, what is
the purpose of our lives
and deaths, the seeming
emphasis on origin and ontology,
on person and place,
is a strange tangle
of temporality, a future
anterior whose complex
representation is of course the
aspiration of great narrative
art.
The poiesis of literature,
painting, ritual,
and even scientific discourse.
Stephen's inspired portrait
of Dürer at work on The Fall
of Man-- and I quote him, "A
figure made up of beautiful
pieces of bodies stitched
together to an idealizing
geometrical scheme,
drawn from a pagan idol,
is a motif of the [INAUDIBLE] of
aesthetic assemblage that gives
the myth of Adam and
Eve its narrative powers
of refreshment, of permanence,
as well as iteration
at the same time."
Myths of origins
are often located
in spaces which become sites
of transgression and expulsion.
They are concurrently
temporalities of transition.
Balanced on the liminal
edge between transgression
and transition,
originary narratives
have the tensile capacity
to endure the pressure that
is required for them to
be extended, repeated,
and revised in time and space.
Stephen's fascination
with the trace
of loss as the locus of
invention or reinvention,
of repetition as the
locus of re-recognition
is at the heart of his
work, both in The Swerve
and his reworking
of Adam and Eve.
But a loss of this kind,
a loss to be found again,
is strangely a gain.
Recovering what is lost,
Stephen once wrote,
requires that, and I quote
him, "one to venture out
to unfamiliar cultural texts.
And these texts, often marginal,
odd, fragmentary, unexpected,
and crude, in turn could begin
to interact in interesting ways
with the intimately familiar
works of the literary canon."
The panel today, of
course, precisely
illustrates this point.
Unfamiliar cultural
texts that Stephen
has turned into
neighbors and friends
and sometimes antagonists coming
together for what I'm sure
will be a very
illuminating discussion.
Thank you all very much
for being here today.
[APPLAUDING]
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Homi, for
the eloquent introduction,
and to the Mahindra Center
for hosting this occasion.
Homi asked me now
some time ago if I
would like to do something
at the Mahindra Center
to mark the publication of
my book on Adam and Eve.
And that was very
gracious of him.
And I said, I would
love to do something.
If we could possibly think
of a way of bringing together
my particular literary
interests with theology
and with evolutionary biology
and with anthropology.
And marvelously here we are.
What we propose to do is speak
very, very briefly, each of us,
for eight to 10 minutes.
And then have some
conversation among ourselves
in the mode of the garden party.
And then open the floor
up to questions from you.
So I will say just a few things
briefly about my own interests,
which--
as I suppose, befits my
disciplinary training--
have to do with fascination
with stories, with narrative,
and with extremely powerful
stories of which this
is probably the single
most spectacular
in the Western tradition
of a story that
had enormous impact,
consequences,
and diffusion in the
world of the Near East
and the West, especially
the Christian world.
The story which
originates, as you I'm sure
know, in the Hebrew world,
probably in an oral culture
that precedes the invention of
what we think of as Judaism,
but goes back probably
well before that.
The story gets picked up,
told, in the Book of Genesis,
gets embraced after considerable
argument by Christianity.
Gets transmitted and enters also
the Muslim world, and therefore
penetrates very fully over
an enormous population
and a huge amount of time.
It's a story that,
as origin stories do,
it's a story, in this case,
and in the very tiny compass,
attempts to explain a great
many things, almost everything.
Certainly, the origin
of our species, also
species dominance, which is
announced in the Genesis story.
It attempts to explain,
or at least give you
a depiction of the
origin of pair bonding,
culminating in that moment
at which the woman is brought
to the man, evidently
taken from the man's body,
but brought back to him, after
what the ancient rabbis thought
was possibly an abortive
attempt to introduce Adam
to the other animals and have
one of them chosen as his mate.
Then, of course, transgression,
and then the origin of shame--
so that a somatic, as well as
a moral or ethical problem.
The nature of labor--
why we have to work and sweat.
Why women experience
excruciating pain
in childbirth.
Why we die.
Why the world
doesn't keep us going
and we can't continue
in the world.
And then a suite of
issues, as so many
of these issues that
I'm describing have,
problems that are in the
boundary between ethics
and biology,
including what appears
to be a curse or a punishment,
as it's described in the Bible,
of male domination of women.
And then what again
the Bible singles out
is something to
think about, the fact
that women continue to
desire the creatures who
dominate them.
It's one of the strangest
things about the Genesis account
is that strange half
a verse, Genesis 3:16,
in which whoever told
the story thought
that it needed explanation,
that it shouldn't be taken
for granted, that
men dominate women,
or that women desire men
in those circumstances,
but needed to be explained as
a punishment for transgression.
That's worth
reflecting, I think,
on, at least it is for
me, a source of surprise.
And it was even a source of
surprise for many commentators
in the 17th century.
In 17th century, a era when this
issue was focused on, of course
it upset the male
theologians who
said of course the men were
intended to dominate women,
even in paradise.
It's just that women would
have enjoyed it more then,
The experience of
finding it disagreeable
must be part of the punishment.
In any case, these issues
are among the reasons
why Joseph coronary
in Art History
and I have taught this course
in the general education
program of ethical
reasoning, because you
can watch the
story as it evolves
as a story about a long-term
project of human attempt
to understand ethical life.
That project, which
continues actually
into the 19th and 20th
century, and much of Homi
said in introducing us about the
liminal or transitional moment,
is precisely what obsessed,
for example, Kierkegaard
in thinking about how you would
get from innocence to guilt
or culpability, what kind of
threshold you'd have to cross.
That kind of ethical thinking,
philosophical thinking,
doesn't involve believing
the story in any sense
is literally true.
But my own book is about the
long-term and extraordinary
project, especially
in Christian culture,
and especially in Christian
culture after St. Augustine,
to believe that
the story can make
people believe that the
story is literally true.
So to defeat, in
effect, the allegorists,
whether they were
Jews like Philo
or Christians like
Origen, and to make
a central doctrine of the faith
be the literal interpretation
of the story of Adam and Eve.
And that continues all the
way into our present world
in which, if we can
believe the polls,
40% of our fellow countrymen
in the United States
profess to believe in the
literal truth of the story,
even though it's
rather difficult
to coordinate that literal
belief with virtually
everything that we know about
the world since at least
the late 18th century.
So the project of making it
literal, of making it real,
as it was understood
by the Renaissance,
is at the very
center of my book.
And that plot, which I won't
take the time to describe now,
has to do with serious
people grappling
with what it means to
make anything real,
but particularly
this story real,
a story about a naked man
and woman and a talking
snake in a magical
garden with weird trees
is not obviously to
be taken literally.
And that was true 2,000 or
3,000 years ago, as well.
They weren't actually
dumber than we are.
So they understood that the
story has all the elements
of a fairy tale or myth.
And to make people actually
think that it is literally true
required an enormous
effort of will,
but also of intelligence,
symbolic intelligence,
and also of art-making.
So that it's a triumph finally
of Renaissance technology
to actually give us Dürer's
Adam and Eve or Michelangelo
or Titian, but also to give
us Milton's Adam and Eve,
to give us creatures who seem
actually to be taken literally,
to be evidence of the
reality of this story.
And those attempts
had to grapple
with the set of things that are
extremely difficult, difficult
already before Darwin came
along in the 19th century
to blow the whole thing open.
But questions, for
example, about how
creatures who evidently
did not know what death
was, because there was
no death in the garden,
could ever understand
what death was.
Or how you begin to speak
if you are apparently
born into the world as an
adult without an infancy
or a childhood.
Or what it would mean
to obey a prohibition if
the prohibition
actually kept you
from knowing the difference
between good and evil--
just lies at the very
center of the story.
That is to say,
people grasped already
several thousand years
ago that this was
a story written by Franz Kafka.
And they struggled
for centuries,
many of the most
interesting, I think, people
in the whole Western tradition
struggled with how to explain,
how to grapple with
things that are
built-in in a deep way,
hardwired into the story.
We will turn to the other
members of the panel now.
But I just want to say that,
hovering at least for me
over our own relation to
the story, my own relation
to the story in
the 21st century,
is to try to understand
when the moral features
that figure so prominently
in the Genesis story--
disobedience, the search for
knowledge, the experience
of shame, the feeling of not
being in the place that you
should be, a feeling of exile--
when did these appear, if, in
the world that we now believe,
must have been the
world of our ancestors,
not Adam and Eve in
the paradisal garden,
but the world of primates.
When could these have
come into the world?
And when into the world did
we get, and how did we get,
symbolic acts?
Did we get aesthetic acts?
Were they already in
our primate ancestors?
Did we get varieties of
cooperation and collaboration
that lead us to the
creatures that we are now?
This is just a way of beginning.
And I'm excited to turn
the microphone over
to Kimberley Patton, who
will pick up from here.
Thank you, Stephen.
I'm honored to be here.
It's always a pleasure
to be in a space
at Harvard that
allows religionists
and scientists to actually
talk to one another.
These are the
conversations we need
to be having, especially now.
As a reminder in the news this
week by a pending Supreme Court
case for a wedding
cake never baked
for two grooms in Colorado,
the story of Adam and Eve
is alive and well in our culture
and protected by the mantle
of religious belief--
or is it?
Adam and Eve, not
Adam and Steve,
continue to run a parallel
race alongside the changing
and contested global
understanding of the range
of human sexualities, the ethics
and political discourse that
result from that, and the civil
protections of legal marriage.
In another lane runs
evolutionary biology
and our evolving
understanding of it.
Yet no one seems to be
staying in their lane.
Reality and our
experience of it continues
to be interdisciplinary, a
palimpsest of many layers.
Freud wrote in
Future of an Illusion
that religion would be
outgrown as science ascended
and human beings became
more willing to let
go of their
paternalistic god figure,
embracing our terrifying
vulnerability and existential
aloneness in an
uncaring universe.
The sociologists of
the 1960s predicted
that religion was atrophying
into a colorful set
of illuminations in the margins
of the pre-Enlightenment.
And my own wonderful
Professor of Paleontology,
Stephen Jay Gould, did not
share Darwin's unhappiness
with the increasing
ascendant role
that evolution plays in the
thinking of some of the world.
And he invited humanity
to get real and grow up
in a world of stasis and sudden
replacement, a world free
of fantasy, free of story--
the real world.
None of this happened.
And lived religion
remains stubbornly
persistent in many areas, more
fundamentally dug in than ever
before.
In the rise of Adam and
Eve, Stephen Greenblatt
is both fascinated and troubled
by the persistence of a tale
that he says bears
the hallmark, and I'm
quoting, "of the imagination
at its most extravagant,
a magical garden, a
naked man and woman
who are brought into
existence in a way
that no other human
beings have been born.
People who know how
to speak and function
without the prolonged
childhood that
is the hallmark of our
species, a mysterious warning
about death that no such newly
created beings could possibly
understand, a
talking snake, a tree
that confers knowledge
of good and evil,
another tree that
confers eternal life,
supernatural guardians
wielding flaming swords."
This is fiction at
its most fictional,
a story that revels in the
delights of make-believe.
Joni Mitchell, left out of
Woodstock through a scheduling
error, wanted it both ways.
We are stardust,
we are golden, we
are 50 billion year old carbon.
And we've got to get
ourselves back to the garden.
The author's
fundamental question
is why Adam and Eve,
whom he argues epitomize,
quote, "the weird, enduring
power of human storytelling
began to bear insistence on
the literal truth," which
he attributes, as he says, to
Christian orthodoxy following
Augustine, and then
into the Renaissance.
How does something made
up become so compellingly
real, he asks.
What happens when
fictional creatures
behave as if they were alive?
Are they fated for that
reason to begin to die.
Professor Greenblatt gives
us some masterful, deeply
researched tale that allows
us to peer both backwards
and forwards in its
genealogy of stories
about the origin of the
cosmos and of humankind,
shedding light on its past
in the ancient Mesopotamian
epics, the Enuma Elish
and the Atra-Hasis,
and later continuing
its story in the Great
Flood of the Sumerian
tale, the Gilgamesh,
which informs the story of Noah.
Many historians find this
story of Adam and Eve
was the [INAUDIBLE] response
to the exile in Babylon,
the Torah being redacted at
the time of Ezra and Nehemiah
in the sixth century BCE.
It appropriates, rewrites, and
ethicizes the creation myths
to which the Jewish
people return,
and to which they were exposed.
The warrior-creator Marduk,
who, when his own grandmother
Tiamat and her chaos
monsters rise up against him,
the salt ocean deep, who was
primordial and never created,
splits her in half to create
the heavens and the Earth.
And out of the god Quingu, who
incited grandmother to riot,
Marduk creates
human beings, Lullu,
to be slaves to the gods.
The Adam and Eve story,
on the other hand,
has one sovereign god who broods
upon the face of the deep,
[NON-ENGLISH],, who, after
creating all the other living
things in the sea and on
earth, as Lyle actually noted,
makes the first pair of human
beings in his own image.
[INAUDIBLE] Elohim, troubling
plural as that remains
in the text, male and
female together in the first
creation--
Adam from the Earth, and
the woman whom he will
name Eve, life, in the second.
They're given dominion
over the creatures.
Adam is tasked with naming them.
They're prohibited
only from eating
the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil,
for they will die.
The serpent tells Eve
that they will not
die, but instead become like
God, knowing good and evil.
And in the heartbreaking
sequence that follows,
including all the terrible
punishments of the pair,
God's preoccupations
become clear.
He says to himself, after
his terrible litany, see,
the man has become like
us, knowing good and evil.
And now he might also
take out his hand
and stretch it to the tree of
life and eat and live forever.
Greenblatt argues that
Genesis as a whole,
and in particular the
Adam and Eve story,
is one that gives us an etiology
of all that afflicts us,
creation and innocence,
lost of temptation,
wrong choices, shame,
sexual desire, labor, death,
and, most tragically of all,
deep alienation between creator
and his created beings.
Durkheim or Foucault
might call it
a reflection of
social engineering,
created from the remains of
ancient Near Eastern stories,
and now patrolling
the boundaries
of the social
realities that matter
to the royal state of Israel.
He gives us not only the
past of the story, where
following recur in the
midst of anteriority,
there is no real beginning.
I would argue that
Adam and Eve of Genesis
do, in fact, have parents.
They're just camouflaged
in the narrative.
Tiamat lives on in
Tehom in Genesis 1.
She's not created,
she's simply there
at the beginning, the deep.
And the shadow of
Marduk is clearly
seen in God the
creator, who separates
the heavens and the Earth, who
orders the lights of heaven,
who makes man from the Earth
and breathes life into him.
As Greenblatt says,
this is a story
in which innocent turns
into wickedness in a flash
without any fair chance
for moral development.
Unlike its predecessors, it
offers an etiology of creation
and, what he calls
so brilliantly,
a reversal of stories, such as
Gilgamesh, where clothing means
belonging, where strife,
love, and encounter with death
and the struggle
over immortality
lead to a restored, not a
lost kingdom, and to wisdom.
Genesis turns this
upside down and, quote,
"rewrites initiation
as transgression."
And it is hard in that powerful,
ritual phrase in this book
not to hear an echo
of the childhood story
that he is brave enough
to share with us.
Looking up, defying
the prohibition
during the blessing
of the Kohanim
during the Jewish liturgy,
because God would be seen,
because that would be
death, instant death.
And Professor Greenblatt
shares that he
sees when he dares look up and
is willing to sacrifice that he
sees not God passing overhead,
but also only empty air
and gossiping adults.
And he writes, "I
had been lied to."
For him, transgression was
initiation into this question.
Now let us think about the word
story versus the word myth.
Story occurs far more often in
this book than the word myth.
But myth means something
different than story.
Muo in the Greek,
or [INAUDIBLE],,
means, I tell in a special way.
It is cognate with
the word mystery.
A myth is a sacred
history, a tale
of origins with moral force,
but often involving-- in fact,
always involving
supernatural creatures.
It has no normal
moral parameters.
It is neither true nor untrue,
right nor wrong, in the sense
that we normally
mean these terms.
Creation stories exist because
of the human commitment
to causality,
Aristotelian or otherwise.
They almost always involve
separating, differentiating,
and demarcating.
Chaos is almost always
replaced by order,
ancient pieces almost
always ruptured,
paradisal gardens are
almost always lost,
ancient unending intercourse
is almost always disturbed.
The fire is almost
always stolen and given
to whom it should
not be, or else that
gift is eternally contested.
The angels protest
and are incinerated.
Iblis protests and is
cast out of heaven.
Something is broken,
something is stolen.
And try as we might to
restore it or replace it,
it is not accomplished.
So the creation story of
Genesis can and should,
I would argue, be studied
alongside other creation
stories from the
world's history--
myths paradoxical, in
some ways beyond ethics.
In many, there is
one creator god,
or there's two, as in the
case of Izanagi and Izanami,
the divine couple,
brother and sister,
who draw the Japanese islands
from the bottom of the sea.
In the Yoruba tradition,
winged beasts sent by Obatala
scratch the Earth
into existence.
Earth-diver pulls it
up from the bottom
of the sea in Native
American mythologies,
or the gods create it
with primal sacrifice
from an egg, or a primal
person, as an Indo-European myth
themes.
There can be many creator gods,
as in the case of the Mayan
Popol Vuh.
Sovereign plume [INAUDIBLE],,
along with heart
of lake and heart of sky.
At a time when only the sea
is pooled under all the sky,
there is nothing
whatever gathered under.
Despite differences, all
of these tales almost
always involve, as
I said, creation
of order from chaos, a
kind of differentiation.
And here we enter into the
question, why make people.
In the Popol Vuh, the gods
say, how should the sowing be
and the dawning.
Who is to be the
provider, the nurturer?
Let this be this way.
Think about it-- the
Earth should be removed,
the water should be
removed, emptied out
for the formation of
the Earth's own plate.
And then comes the sowing
and the dawning of sky earth.
But there will be no high
days and no bright praise
for our work, our design, until
the rise of the human work,
the human design.
Maker, modeller,
begetter of the Mayans,
create humans to sow the
land, as Marduk does.
Although in a gentler way,
God takes multiple tries,
unlike the god of Genesis.
Human generations are mud,
wood, and finally maize people,
the final draft.
Yggdrasil, reversing
the Genesis story,
hides the primal couple,
Lif and Lifthrasir, life
and life's partner, after all
of the gods and the whole world
are destroyed.
The Pacific Northwest
trickster figure, the raven,
creates people on the beach
just because he's bored.
Often, we hear that God
needs laborers, but he also,
or they also need company.
They need a way to be known
and understood, to be mirrored.
Ibn Arabi writes in the Fusus,
"I was a hidden treasure,
and I yearned to be
known in God's name."
Another feature of
creation epics--
and I don't have time
to go into this--
is the notion of alienation
of god, the god who
is removed, or removes himself.
And we find this
not only in Africa,
but in many other myths of
creation, including this one.
Just to give one example,
among [INAUDIBLE] people
in Togo, [INAUDIBLE]
ends up removing himself
from a very intimate
space with humans
because people keep hitting
him with their pestles
when they grind.
The smoke of the cooking
fires gets into his eyes.
And worst of all, an old woman,
anxious to make a good soup,
used to cut off a bit of
him at each meal time.
And God, being pained at
this treatment, went higher.
So there is a way in
which the loss of intimacy
and God's loneliness
at the exile
figures as well into the
sadness and the sorrow
and the disruption, although
the book does not dwell on that.
In conclusion, I would
argue that theologically
the notion that
we have to choose
between a story of
randomness and lost
rivulets of dead-end evolution
on the way to the sea,
of traits only inherited
because they're envelopes of DNA
more likely to be passed on
to other envelopes of DNA,
and so that they will
not be annihilated,
versus a fairy tale
of primal parents
and talking snakes
with a gardener
god who builds a
booby trap for them,
is perhaps a false dichotomy.
And I wish The Rise and
Fall of Adam and Eve,
this brilliant book, did
not cleave so closely to it.
Myths often encodes or
responds to history.
It is not necessarily
a story told apart
from historical experience.
Plato's Cave, as it turns out,
as I discovered to my shock
in Greece, ends up
being an actual cave.
And it exactly resembles the one
as mentioned in The Republic.
Plato played there as
a child, for example.
There is evidence of
an enormous flood.
Geologist William
Ryan and Walter Pitman
worked on it for 30 years.
It happened around 5,600
BC in the Black Sea.
And it involved the
collapse of an earthen dam
in the Bosphorus.
They called their book Noah's
Flood and thereby set off,
I would argue, it's dismissal,
which is unfortunate,
because it could be
that the many flood
myths do carry at
least some trace
of historical memory of it.
And perhaps we could
flip that notion
and we could say that why should
we not think of evolution not
as a story or a parallel
story, but as a myth,
with all of the
paradox and wonder,
strangeness and beauty
that the story of
Adam and Eve holds,
a story told in a special way.
As surely a story that can
be manipulated to evil ends,
just as Adam and Eve can
be, as Stephen notes,
the eugenics movement,
the randomness,
the causal randomness,
bringing with it
its own form of despair, such
as perhaps Darwin experienced.
From the standpoint of
sheer evolutionary biology,
we human beings are actually
a predatory invasive species
that's radically dominated
our environmental niche.
But that means that religion
and storytelling and myth-making
and meaning-making is as much
a part of evolution as anything
else that we readily
identify with it,
as much as stasis and
sudden replacement.
So turning the tables,
we delude ourselves
if we see scientific inquiry
and knowledge as not a story,
and by which I mean
not a sacred history.
Perhaps this was Stephen
Jay Gould's insight.
Perhaps we do live in a
magical universe in which time
can bend, the trees
in a forest can
communicate with one another.
Where my parakeet has an
ancestor in massive dinosaurs
120 million years ago.
Where those same
dinosaurs turn out to have
had feathers and could sing.
A magical universe where
dung beetles known as scarabs
turn to use the stars to
navigate their perfectly
straight routes across
the desert at night
so that when their
little heads are covered,
they run in crazy zigzags.
Where the Neanderthal
versus Lucy,
the Neanderthal is
my direct ancestor--
4%.
Where giraffes turn
out to have a form
of communicative language.
It was just too pitched too high
for us to be able to detect it,
until recently.
Where creatures living
near sulfurous vents
seven miles below
the Earth's surface
can thrive in pressure that
would make a human head
explode.
Where the coelacanth that was
supposed to have gone extinct
30 million years ago turns up
in a fish market in Sulawesi.
Where chimpanzees dance before
a waterfall in Tanzania.
When it rains and rabbits
kick their feet in the air
when they leap for no reason.
Where invertebrates such
as giant Pacific octopi
show individual personality
traits and facial recognition.
A magical universe
where pregnant mothers
and their fetuses swap
entire populations of cells
across the placental barrier,
osmotic as it turns out.
And those cells, called
microchimera, little monsters,
stay swapped and subdividing
so that none of us
is a hermetically
sealed individual.
And Homo sapiens mothers
and their children
represent an unbroken
enchainement, all the way back,
not to four female
individuals who
lived between 160,000
and 200,000 years ago,
as was believed in the
1980s, but it's now
been shown to be only one,
living almost certainly
in what is now Ethiopia.
Is this fiction at its
most fictional, a story
that revels in the
delights of make-believe?
This is perhaps instead the
random, purposeful, mystical
world that we have
inherited, the garden that we
are trying so hard to
exile ourselves from.
And as we know, geneticists have
given our common grandmother
a name--
Mitochondrial Eve.
Stephen Greenblatt's
beautiful book
shows that perhaps they
could not help themselves.
Thank you.
[APPLAUDING]
OK, well, thank you, Kimberley.
And thank you, Stephen.
Thank you, Homi.
It's great to see an attempt to
bring humanities and scientists
together.
I'm meant to be a scientist.
So I haven't had time to
read all of Stephen's books.
So in order to do some research
for this, I did what all of us
would do--
I turned to the web.
If you look up Adam
and Eve on the web,
then you find yourself looking
at a page all about sex toys.
So I went back to nature.
Nature Communications this
week had a paper published
about hunter-gatherers.
"Hunter-Gatherers" is a
very sad story, of course,
because we come from
hunter-gatherers.
And hunter-gatherers living
in the wild in the way
that our ancestors once did,
we are in the generation
that is seeing the end of that.
We're losing that tie to
our evolutionary past.
But people are quickly
getting data where they can
on people living as close to
a real hunter-gatherer life as
possible.
And there were 18 groups
in the Philippines of Agta
who were studied
for storytelling.
And the stories
they tell seem to me
to resonate exactly
with what we're hearing
about with Adam and Eve.
They are mythic in
all sorts of ways.
And in fact, in this
particular study, what
they were able to show is
that among 18 different camps,
they varied in the quality
of the storytellers
as rated by other people.
They looked at
200 or 300 people.
And it turns out that
the better storytellers
have camps in which there is
more cooperation, as measured
with economic games.
And by the way, the
better storytellers
have more children.
They benefit themselves.
And the stories they tell are
like, Kimberley was saying
and Stephen was saying,
they bring social order.
They tell stories of
hierarchy and organization
and division and
indeed cooperation.
So when we find that 56% of
people in the United States
believe that Adam and
Eve were real people,
and that 44% of them believe
so with strong or absolute
certainty, then that to me
is something about the way
that people organize
themselves to cooperate
in terms of their shared
belief in something that
is incredible.
Well, I'm a scientist.
Scientists tell stories.
Kimberley was trying
to suggest that we tell
equivalent kinds of stories.
I think in some ways they
are equivalent because they
are beautiful and creative.
But I think in other ways
they're not equivalent
because I don't think they
have the same social function.
They have different
social functions.
I don't think they serve to
help bring people together
around a specific kind of shared
belief, only about the belief
that science matters.
And I'll just draw
attention to two ways
in which we can tie the Adam
and Eve story to science.
One is the genetics,
so just building
on what Kimberley
was saying, actually.
In 1987, Rebecca
Cann used the fact
that mitochondria have
very little recombination.
They're in all our cells,
and the occasional mutation
happens, and we can work
out the mutation rates.
And you can work out
when it was that you
have the last individual
who was the common ancestor
for everybody living
on the Earth today.
And what Cann did in 1987 was
say it's about 200,000 years.
And now the estimate is
150,000 to 200,000 years ago.
And I'll add to that
by looking at Adam.
So mitochondria passed
through the maternal lines,
and then you have the Y
chromosome passed down
the paternal lines.
And they only very rarely
have any crossing over
with the matching X chromosome.
So again, there are
some uncertainties
in the calculations,
but the last Adam
who gave rise to all the
people living today, it
was estimated to be between
200,000 and 300,000 years ago.
So whether or not Eve
actually met Adam is unclear.
Whether or not they lived
at the same time is unclear.
They might have lived as
much as 150,000 years apart.
So we have to just adjust
the story just a little bit.
So that's the genetic angle.
Let me just mention briefly
about the social behavior
angle.
Stephen mentioned
about Adam and Eve
being a story among
many different things,
but partly it is about bonding.
And the fact that there is
only one Eve and one Adam
pushes one in the
direction of thinking
it's about monogamy,
which it seems very
strange because the ancient
Israelites were certainly
not monogamous.
But it can be said to
be about pair bonding,
and then that fits with what
the Israelites were like.
But still just to think about
monogamy just very briefly,
and one could really say the
same thing about bonding,
about bonding in
general, it's not
very common in the
primates as a whole.
Most of the primates have a
much more liberal attitude,
a sort of Harvey
Weinstein attitude
to their sexual relationships.
Something like 10%
can be said to be
monogamous, that sort of thing.
If you survey human
societies, then monogamy
is common within the societies,
but rare between societies.
That is to say, the great
majority of human societies,
75%, 80% that sort of thing,
are polygynous in the sense
since that they welcome
polygyny, they allow it.
But most people, in fact,
end up monogamously married.
Now there is a difference
between the bonding
that you see in
humans and the bonding
non-human primates, which
is due to the way
that they move about.
In the monogamous primates, they
travel together all the time,
the male and the female.
It's like what happens
after you retire.
I'll leave you to get
the implications of that.
But the reason appears
to be that when
a primate male bonds
with a primate female,
he does not trust what she is
up to, unless he is with her.
He has to guard her as a mate.
So now then think about humans.
If you look at any
hunter-gatherer population
in the world, or any
population of humans anywhere
in the world, regardless
of their subsistence type,
males and females do not
spend all their time together,
especially in their
reproductive years.
The women go one
way, and the men
go another, if you're in
hunter-gatherer society.
And then they come
together in the evenings.
In fact, they spend very
little time together.
It's very difficult
to find a photograph
of a male and a
female hunter-gatherer
who are married to each
other being together.
You only do it by asking them,
please, will you sit together.
They say, what, that's crazy.
So in order to have a mate
guarding a relationship,
how do humans do it?
The answer is we do
it through language.
We have gossip that allows
us to check what each of you
are doing during the day.
And so there's lots of evidence
that that's what's happening.
So if you're going to
think about the evolution
of human bonding, you have
to think about mate guarding
and you have to
think about language.
Well, for my own part, I
will take a view on language.
But different people might
take different views.
But for various
reasons, I'm impressed
with the evidence that language
is the key to understanding
the evolution of Homo sapiens.
Thanks to a paper
published last year,
the date of the
evolution of Homo sapiens
has been pushed back
from 170,000 years ago
to 315,000 years ago in Morocco.
And you never find literally
the earliest things.
So probably it's a little
bit earlier than that.
And if language
indeed emerged then,
that would be the time
when, for the first time,
humans were able to meet God.
They could not do
so before, I think,
because we know what the
toddlers looked like.
We know enough about
locomotor mechanics
to know that the toddlers
were walking extremely slowly
and basically had
to be kept in camp.
And that means that
the women and the men
really had to be doing
something different.
It's not like the
non-human primates
where a male and
the female gibbon
can swing cheerfully from
tree to tree together,
and their baby comes with them.
So the story that
I want to convey
from the evolutionary
anthropology perspective
is that if we think
about Adam and Eve
from the point-of-view
of bonding, then
there is a convergence
with the notion of story,
because the language that
emerged enabling people
to check what each other
were doing during the day
is the same language that would
have produced the stories that
were told around the campfire
from at least 300,000
years ago, stories that
would have included
hunter-gatherer equivalents
of Adam and Eve.
Thank you.
[APPLAUDING]
Many thanks to
Homi and to Stephen
for including me
in this occasion,
and to Kimberley and Richard
for your beautiful papers.
In the final paragraph of
On the Origin of Species,
Charles Darwin guides
the reader in an exercise
on how to look at
nature through the eyes
of evolutionary theory.
It's interesting, he suggests
with characteristic mildness,
"to contemplate an
entangled bank, closed
with many plants of many
kinds, with birds singing
on the bushes, with various
insects flitting about,
and with worms crawling
through the Earth,
and to reflect that these
elaborately constructed forms,
so different from each
other and dependent on each
other in so complex a manner,
have all been produced
by laws acting around us."
Though Darwin's words share
with invocations of Eden,
their imagery of
proliferation of an exhaustive
and teeming roster
of all that lives,
this is no deliberately
staged garden.
Divine law is
nowhere in evidence.
The blind and soulless actors,
Darwin goes on to name, are--
and these are all
capitalized in his text--
Growth and Reproduction,
Inheritance, Variability,
the Struggle for Life,
and Natural Selection,
leading not only to divergence
of character or speciation,
but to extinction.
This is a story
that extinguishes
as much as it creates.
There exists an eerie similarity
between Darwin's language here
and the words chosen
by Stephen Greenblatt
to describe the
experience of visiting
a paleoanthropology
lab and contemplating
the dizzying nonlinearity of
fossil evidence for hominin
evolution.
"It is difficult to find the
story in a tangled bush,"
he writes, playing on the
branching, tree-like structures
that evolutionary thinkers use
to illustrate relationships
of ancestry and
descent among species.
The narrative of human evolution
looks from this perspective
less like an act of creation
or a march of progress
than, quote, "a wilderness
of discontinuous
and criss-crossing
tracks," end quote.
Despite the
confidence with which
Darwin imbues his
final paragraph,
the idea that a properly
attuned act of looking
will yield the truth of
the evolutionary story,
Stephen identifies an
unavoidable feature of Darwin's
theory as it applies to
human origins, quote,
"that this account happens to
be true according to our best
scientific lights
does not in itself
make it good to think with.
On the contrary, its
difficulty, its uncertainties,
its resistance to
narrative coherence
makes it one of the great
challenges of our age,"
end quote.
Although Darwin himself did not
address human origins in print
until 1871, other
19th century thinkers
were eager to work through
evolutionary theory's
human implications.
They began to ask another of
Stephen's central questions,
one that Renaissance
artists took up
with particular passion, what
were the first people like.
While naturalists
like Thomas Huxley
drew their favorite evidence
from the anatomical and
embryological similarities
between humans
and other primates,
cultural evolutionists
began to think through what
the earliest humans were
like using a different source--
ethnographic reports, their own
and those of others-- and this
is a pretty heterogeneous group
of documents-- on the life
ways of small-scale societies.
The words I just used, life
ways and small-scale societies,
would have been neither familiar
nor coherent to a 19th century
thinker.
Instead, those
thinkers described
the conditions of those
outside the ambit of Western
Europe and its
cultural offshoots,
or the lower races of man
with taxonomic gradations,
including savagery
and barbarism.
These labels were as technical
and anthropology as lunatic
and idiot were in late
19th century English law.
Lewis Henry Morgan
explains in Ancient Society
that they serve to classify
both peoples and time
periods according to
modes of subsistence,
technological innovations,
geographic distribution,
and degree of literacy.
The overlap of social
and temporal categories
is crucial here.
It underlines a cornerstone of
cultural evolutionary logic,
small-scale societies
are atavisms,
living examples
of earlier stages
through which civilized
19th-century populations once
passed.
And we see what can sometimes
be a complicated echo of this,
though much updated in
contemporary evolutionary
anthropology's engagement with
hunter-gatherer societies.
"In the sciences of
law and society,"
John Ferguson
McLennan wrote, "old
means not old and
chronology, but in structure.
That is most archaic
which lies nearest
to the beginning of
human progress considered
as a development.
And that is most modern
which is farthest
removed from that beginning."
Subsistent strategies,
technologies,
and language
capabilities, that is,
could be arranged in a hierarchy
from primitive to complex.
The developmental sequence
of any given society
would be charted as a
journey up that hierarchy.
There was, however, a problem.
Morgan admitted in his
taxonomy of human development
that there existed
no human population
in the late 19th
century that persisted
in the most primitive human
state, known as the lower
status of savagery, in
which humans first used
fire and began to
speak, but had not yet
invented the bow and arrow.
So perhaps something of
what Richard is imagining
with the first Adam and Eve.
Conjuring this period,
quote, "the infancy
of the human race,"
end quote, therefore
required an act of
imagination, the generation
of a coherent narrative.
A strategy adopted by
several prominent cultural
evolutionists,
including Morgan, relied
on a form of deep reading.
Human rituals and
words, they claimed,
move along a trajectory from
the literal to the symbolic.
The more civilized
we become, the more
distant our cultural
practices and words
from the utterly concrete
form in which they originated.
A father used not to walk
his daughter down the aisle
in a gesture emblematic of
the end of her childhood
and the beginning of
sociological maturity.
He literally gave her away,
though probably in exchange
for something of
value from the family
of his future son-in-law.
A groom did not carry his
bride over the threshold
of their new home for
reasons of romance.
He had to bind her in his arms
because he had captured her
from her tribe, and
she might run away.
It was even easier to infer
the earliest human version
of a practice from a more
primitive society, one closer
to the source.
Morgan and colleagues,
including Sir John Lubbock,
took their methods
a step further.
Not only did the kinship
arrangements and marriage
practices of savages
and barbarians
provide a window into human
prehistory, but they proposed,
contained in the
terms of kinship
themselves, in the
words people use
to describe their
relationships to one
another, the keen
observer could find
the key to primordial
human social structures.
Europeans use a form
of kinship terminology
that they label
descriptive, in which
terms like aunt, grandfather,
stepmother, and son-in-law
give precise information
about the nature and degree
of connection between parties.
But compared to Mandarin,
from what I understand,
romance and Germanic
languages are actually
pretty generalized.
For example, we
use the word aunt
to describe our mother's
sisters, our father's sisters,
and the wives of our mother's
brothers on both sides.
So it's descriptive
only to a point.
But at the other extreme,
small-scale societies
that Morgan and others
encountered employed much more
inclusive terminology.
And they called this
not descriptive,
but classificatory.
The same word might
be used to identify
a man's wife, his wife's
sister, his brother's wife,
and his wife's brother's wife.
So these are all kind of
the same kinship term.
At the most inclusive level, the
only kinship terms recognized
would translate as mother,
father, wife, husband, son,
and daughter.
Vertical generational
differences and differences
of sex were the only ones
preserved by these terms.
If rituals of gift giving,
marriage, and diplomacy
were distant echoes
of literal enactments,
then the language
of kinship surely
symbolized the
actual relationships
it originated to describe.
In the earliest days of
classificatory kinship, terms
and societies, Lubbock
claimed, all the men and women
of a single generation not
only called one another wife
and husband, but in fact
behaved as wife and husband
to one another, participating
in what he delicately
called promiscuous marriage.
Paternity would have been
unknown, and maternity
inconsequential, because the
children belonged to the tribe.
Lubbock's version
of early society,
titillating foreign to the
sexual mores of his readership,
reinforced the narrative of
amorality and backwardness
among largely
brown-skinned people
that helped to justify
British colonial projects.
When Darwin came
at last to write
about human origins
in The Descent of Man,
and Selection in Relation
to Sex, much of his book
did not concern humans at all.
The vast catalog of evidence
for sexual selection in insects,
fish, birds, and mammals is
bookended by two discussions
of Homo sapiens.
The first establishes
human antiquity
and biological continuity
with other species.
And the second, which
occurs at the end,
takes the differences
in physical appearance
among human populations as
evidence for sexual selection.
Different people find
different things attractive.
And this has resulted in
population differentiation.
To make the case for
sexual selection in humans,
Darwin engages the theories
of prehistoric marriage
and kinship articulated by
Morgan, McLennan, and Lubbock.
He treats them respectfully,
but in the event
he disagrees with them.
Perhaps because his
own experiences,
which Stephen describes, of
savages from Tierra del Fuego
did not include evidence
of promiscuity, or perhaps
because the idea that early
humans made it indiscriminately
was for Darwin an
ethical bridge too far.
To go back to the ethical
resonances of these stories,
he turned to what he knew
of non-human primates.
Close-range, longitudinal
field studies
of primate behavior of the
kind that Richard conducts
were still a century away.
So Darwin had very limited
evidence to work with.
And drawing on what
he had, he concluded
that male apes
manifested the same kind
of pair-bonded sexual
jealousy and protectiveness
of their young as did civilized
modern European human men.
So he's kind of
projecting this image.
Female primate's sexuality
thus was and always had
been restrained.
This story conferred for Darwin
a form of narrative coherence.
I want to close
with an observation
and then open discussion with
a question for the panel.
The observation is this--
in both broadly
Judeo-Christian and Western
scientific imaginings
of human origins,
the question of how our
species came into being
is closely linked with
visions of our earliest
reproductive arrangements.
Whether we are made of dirt
in the image of the divine
or descended from clever,
arboreal knuckle walkers,
our mating systems
in these stories
are governed by
hierarchy and by rules.
What do any of our
panelists think drives
this particular fascination?
Are we merely describing
the inevitable?
Is this a descriptive act?
Or are we grappling
with something
that, as Claude Levi-Strauss
claimed about incest,
has to be regulated,
has to be narrativized
because instinct unbounded would
threaten a fundamental tenet
of human society.
So in shorter terms, are
these stories we have to tell?
Thank you.
[APPLAUDING]
Well, I can perhaps just
start by, first of all,
thanking the three of
you, again, and responding
to Meredith's last
question by resuming
a conversation I had very,
very briefly with Richard.
And I'm sure I'll get
all of this wrong.
As far as I know, what
happens to early humans,
to mark early humans
as bipedalism,
we come down from the trees
and start walking on two legs,
we stopped knuckle-walking.
And that seems to be associated
with also a reduction in size
of canines.
Our canines, we have
them, but they're
much smaller than those
of our primate cousins.
And I said, rather
rationally, that it must be,
to pick up Meredith's
point, that somehow
the reduction of canines must
be a sign of a renegotiation
of sexual relations, because
the canines in chimpanzees
and gorillas must be used in
establishing male dominance.
And then you said, no,
I was completely wrong.
So let's start there.
And then we can maybe figure
out the deeper question
that Meredith is
asking, why we care
so much about these arrangements
anyway in our origin stories.
Well, that's the great segue
about what Australopithecines
were doing.
So what you're talking about
is three or four million years
ago.
The genus Homo came out
about two million years ago.
And then six million
years ago, we
came from a
chimpanzee-like ancestor.
And you said, we came
down from the trees.
Excuse me for this aside,
but we didn't come down
from the trees.
What we did was to shift from
quadrupedal walking in forests
to bipedal walking
in more savannas.
But we still went
up in the trees,
and the chimps spend a lot of
time on the ground right now.
So there's no reason to
think that we actually
changed the amount of time
we spent on the ground.
The point, though, is that
the Australopithecines
by the time you get to three
or four million years ago,
though not earlier, have got
these very reduced canines.
And as you say,
absolutely rightly,
they have been attributed to
reduced fighting among males,
which they associate
with more monogamy.
I gave my reasons a few minutes
ago for why you wouldn't
expect monogamy at that time.
And the logic about the reduced
teeth is now, I would say,
predominantly
referred to eating.
And what's going on is that
this shift into more open areas
is associated with
a change in the diet
to things that you'd
spend longer chewing
and that you need stronger
muscles to be able to chew,
and namely roots, roots
and tubers coming out
of the ground.
And if you look at carnivores
or ungulates or primates,
where they are
doing more chewing,
then the muscles come
forward, the gape of the mouth
is reduced, and therefore the
weapons at the end of the mouth
just get in the way.
You can't afford long
canines because you
have a relatively
narrow gape in order
to be able to accommodate
really effective chewing.
So I would say
that many people--
I mean, I hesitate to speak
for the whole discipline--
but a popular view is that
the reason for the reduction
in those canines is to do
with better chewing and not
reduced fighting.
So in terms of the
Genesis account,
it's God's words about being
vegetarians and eating as many
of the fruits, except for
one, that really counts,
and not the ecstatic sexual
bond between the male
and the female.
Well, you can say that.
Of course, the
ancestry of primates
goes back a long
way of eating stuff.
But this is eating
roots, in particular,
that enforces the chewing.
I wanted to challenge
the premise.
I'm sure I'm wrong,
but I know of a number
of cosmological stories
which do not involve mating.
Absolutely.
And I wanted to draw attention
to the fact that a lot of them
seem to me to refer
to relationships
between men and
women of dominance,
as was being discussed earlier.
And that seems to me to
be really fascinating.
And Kimberley, you
drew attention to this.
It's certainly puzzling-- in
a world in which men always
are dominant, why do you need
stories to reinforce that?
That was Richard--
that was Stephen's--
Oh, is is Stephen?
Sorry.
Stephen's concern.
And I agree, Richard, that
creation stories always
reflect the preoccupations
of the society telling them.
And when we say that, we need
to be not overly sociological,
because the relationships
between human beings
and supernatural beings
is, I would argue,
usually the most important.
We tend to, because we
live in the age we do,
be extremely anthropocentric.
But that does not mean that
these stories were negotiating
relationships with
the powers that
live us, that we
pretend to understand,
as [INAUDIBLE] said,
was the central concern.
And so one of the sadness,
the breakages that
occurs in the Genesis story
that Stephen doesn't dwell on
is God remaining in the garden.
God is lonely, he remains there.
And what's interesting is that
the Jewish mystical tradition
argues that part of God
actually gets split off.
The lowest [INAUDIBLE],, the
Shekhinah, the feminine part
of God actually goes
into exile with Adam
and Eve, weeps with them, is
cut off from the rest of God.
And so you end up
with this yearning
for reunion and return.
And that is what it ends up in
the temple between the Keruvim,
between the Cherubim,
the holy of holies.
And that is what goes
into exile when the temple
itself is destroyed and ends up
being incarnate as the Sabbath
queen at Shabbat.
So God himself is
left lonely as well.
But anyway, the negotiation
of human relationships
with invisible powers,
if we're thinking
about the Paleolithic
or Neolithic period,
we have to include the dead
who are metaphysical, who are
much more powerful than living.
That relationship
has to be negotiated.
And what's interesting--
for example,
I was working at Catalhoyük
for three different seasons,
working with
archaeologists there--
is the way that that ends
up getting literalized, too.
The dead have to
be under the floor,
or you can't build the house.
There has to be a dead
baby in the southwest
corner of the house,
or you can't build it.
Nowadays?
Oh, no, no, no.
This is 9,000 years ago.
OK, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So the dead--
Just to be clear.
We tend to think of the dead
as different from the gods--
but we shouldn't.
In most societies, the dead are
powerful, metaphysical beings.
In fact, they may have been
the source of later theologies
that are more developed.
So I would agree,
not all cosmogonies
are interested in patrolling
sex or reproduction.
Many of them have
other concerns.
Well, I'm aware of
this from reading
some of the
hunter-gatherer literature
where you often find this story
of why it is that men end up
controlling women.
And you get the perspective
that it's an endlessly used
justification.
And the idea that seems
to me to be appealing here
is that in the public
arena it's clear
that men are dominant to
women, but in the private arena
it's not.
In other words, within a
husband and wife relationship,
then either the man
or the woman might be
socially dominant to the other.
Right.
But it's not true
in the public arena.
And so these stories
enable the men
to appeal to a wisdom that is
agreed in the public level.
That's patriarchal.
To justify their
patriarchy within the home.
It's so interesting you say
that because for example
at Catalhoyük, the
anthropologists were
so startled to discover that men
and women have the same amount
of stress in their bones, the
same amount of weight-bearing,
that the labor was in
fact equally divided.
And I'm not saying it was a
proto-egalitarian society,
but that was very surprising.
They were also
surprised to discover
that the skeletons
that are routinely
buried under the floors
of the houses, up to 30
in some cases--
this was a shocker--
through dental phenotyping,
were not related to one another.
So again, back to
Meredith's notion of the way
that family and kinship
groups can be very differently
culturally appropriated
and distributed, depending
on where we are in the world.
It sounds like in
house societies,
there's been recent evidence,
from what I understand,
in hunter-gatherer societies
even that ritual or fictive
kinship can be as binding
in a way that people--
Exactly.
Distribute time and
energy and resources as--
Exactly.
Genetic forms of kinship.
And child-rearing, perhaps, and
food distribution, all of it.
I want to ask, to put
a little pressure,
this is partly a response to
Kimberley's calling me out
as the village atheist,
which I suppose I am,
because it's true that
the reason I think
you're right in
observing that in my case
I spend too little time thinking
about the strange haunting
quality of Adam and Eve hearing
the voice of God in the garden,
and then hiding themselves.
So it's not that God is
withdrawing from them,
but they're hiding.
They're now in a
position of hiding.
But it has to do
with my difficulty,
I think, grappling with what
to do with the belief in God
that I think can't fit--
but Richard may correct me-- in
our current scientific account
of human origins.
It is possible that you could
construct a narrative in which
some part of your--
how shall we say--
life frame you
can acknowledge the
existence of a god.
I don't know how, but
I imagine you can.
But not in the
evolutionary story,
if I understand the
evolutionary story.
There isn't a way in
which the creature who
was described in this,
in various forms,
in so many of the other
of the origin stories,
there's no equivalent figure.
I take it that that
was the whole force
of the scientific effort of
the late 18th and 19th century
to try to get that figure
out of the origin story.
Well, that's a funny way of
reading Darwin, isn't it?
Because I thought that
Darwin's point was he
found it rather
agonizing, that you
have to give up God
in order to understand
the way that evolution worked.
All right, I don't mean that
was done gleefully or easily.
No.
But that it was part of--
it was built in.
It was a consequence.
Right, it was a perhaps
unintended consequence.
And an interesting
moment happened--
so Darwin is in correspondence
with Asa Gray, who
is a really famous biologist,
actually, here at Harvard.
And Asa Gray is also
a committed theist.
And Darwin is disappointed.
He finds himself disappointed
to see how hard Asa Gray is
working to try to reconcile
evolutionary accounts
with some role for God.
And so he does, I think,
what a lot of people
with faith and also who
believe in evolution do,
which is he defers God's
role farther and farther back
in the process, a kind of a--
Watchmaker.
A watchmaker, but
also his original take
was that it was God who put the
favorable variations in there
among all the
not-so-favorable ones.
And Darwin is
getting these letters
from Asa Gray, who
he just loves dearly
and who has been
his defender here,
and who has been baiting Louis
Agassiz, like it's his job.
And Darwin is just reading these
letters, saying, oh my god.
And I think that
for him is actually
a moment when he sees
how disappointed he
is in Gray trying
to fit God in there,
when he really has to come
face-to-face with how, for him
at least personally, there
isn't a space for God
in this narrative.
And this is, in his relationship
with his wife Emma, a big deal.
There are two points
in their relationship
when she writes him letters
because she's so agonized.
One is right after
they get married
and they've moved
to London and she's
hoping for rounds of
theater and visitors,
and Darwin is hoping for
quiet time in his study.
And so they have
all these newlywed,
figuring-it-out moments.
And in the midst of
this, she is also
realizing how much
more committed
she is to faith than he is.
And so she writes him a
very gentle but really
heart-wrenching letter
about the goodness in him
and hoping that
he'll be able to come
to a place of
reconciliation with God.
And she doesn't do it again
until after The Origin
of Species has been published.
And she's starting to
see the consequences,
and they've lost a couple
of their beloved children.
And she has really needed
God to get her through that,
and he is walking
farther and farther away.
So that's the site of
their second moment
of reckoning on that.
What I take to be
Kimberley's response
in your beautiful
presentation to this
is in effect what was Lucretia's
response, which is you
don't have to give up wonder.
You don't have to give up
the sense of the marvelous
in the world.
You just have to
give up the idea
that there's a
metaphysical order that
is creating all of this, moving
the pieces around, rewarding
and punishing.
I think, Stephen, and
I don't in any way
intend to fudge the answer,
but I think all of us,
and I include myself, are
to some degree held hostage
to the notion of God as
a really great uncle.
And I even found it in
your book that he's kind,
that he's merciful,
that he's just.
He's not those things.
He's not even those things
in the Hebrew Bible.
He's fighting between his
mercy and his justice.
He prays that his mercy
may overcome his justice
and all his other
attributes in the Tanakh.
The Hebrew Bible is full of his
arbitrary cruelty, his might,
endless creative energy.
Yeah, John Levinson has argued
that he never really overcomes
chaos and has to fight
it to the end of time.
So he's I think beyond
some of the categories that
tend to emerge.
I think the thing
that gets us hung up
is the notion of
intentionality, right?
That we see these wonderful and
beautiful and amazing things
that continually confound
us with their awe-inspiring
dimensions in science, including
some of the terrible things
that science reveals
to us through research,
and we think that
can't be intentional.
But my point is,
myth is not about
rational metaphysical
involvement
in the world on God's part.
It's not about intentionality.
It's always
paradoxical, it's always
impossible to understand.
But the great mysteries in
human experience are also.
So I don't think that the
split between rationality
and irrationality that
comes through in the book--
or fantasy, should
we say-- is really
the level that we want to stop.
That was my only point.
No, I take it.
I think I understand.
In relation to where we
are now, and I don't think
I resolved this at
all in the book.
I can't resolve it.
I think one key question
about the origin stories
is who gets to tell them.
Right.
And we haven't resolved that
struggle now in our classrooms,
in our schools.
And we're actually
in some ways still
having key arguments about this
that have real consequences
and stakes.
So my goal in the
book is not to--
I wouldn't have bothered
to write a book about--
Right.
The story of Adam and
Eve, even if I just
thought it was something
that didn't count and should
be brushed aside, I
think it's incredibly
powerful and beautiful.
I want it to be powerful
and beautiful as a work
of literature, not as an
origin story that somehow
has a place at the table
with the origin story
that Richard and Meredith
are trying to tell.
Yeah, but we know
that when speaking
to people about the
myths that animate them,
that give meaning
to their lives--
and I include myself,
and all of us,
we all have them,
whatever they are--
that the presentation of
"facts," quote, unquote,
is not the way to combat them.
And why do they
have to be combated?
In other words, what is getting
us so animated and so angry
at this point, for example,
in our country's history?
Do we really need to fight
the story of Adam and Eve
with creation?
Are these two
antagonistic, I wonder?
Even without a kind
of violent synthesis,
does it need to be violent?
I'm not sure.
But I do know that
sitting at Harvard
and throwing up our
hands and saying,
can you believe that 46%
or 50% of the country
actually believes this
story is not bringing us
into more of a conversation.
It's pulling us apart.
And perhaps that is
the wrong question.
Perhaps the battle is
not pitched in that way.
Perhaps it's not a battle.
That's my only point, I think.
And I teach some of that
percent at UMass, Boston.
And this is something I'm
curious, if the rest of you
have encountered
in your pedagogy.
I teach the Introduction
to Human Evolution
in our Anthropology department.
And every semester,
at least one student,
whether privately on a beginning
of semester questionnaire,
or publicly sometimes in
front of the entire class,
asks me a question about
either how their faith fits,
or sometimes the terms
are really stark-- well,
what about Jesus is a question
that has been posed to me once
two minutes before class--
and as I was scribbling
on the board.
And my instinct has been to
try to not be antagonistic,
to try to create a space--
one story I told was about when
different kinds of evidence
become available and how
we work with the evidence
that we have in
any given moment.
But that I think is
unsatisfying to people
for whom particular
forms of evidence
don't really carry
water, or perhaps they
carry the water only so far.
And then like leaky
baskets, it all leaks out.
So this is something
that I'm still
very much grappling
with in a practical way
because there seems
something sacred to identity
in those professions of
faith that one does not
wish to denigrate.
Yeah, and my only point
is that faith also
interacts with history
and historicity in ways
that we're still kind of--
so on our side the
fact that last week it
was revealed that the Crusader
tomb at the Holy Sepulcher
was in fact removed to
reveal a fourth century--
third century-- fourth
century covering as Eusebius
had described it.
Underneath, there was a Jewish
tomb with a shelf in it.
And the response,
if one is discussing
that, which doesn't mean
that the Resurrection is
true or untrue, it just means
that that was what was found.
So there's more historicity
to the oral and other written
accounts than we had thought.
That is met here generally
with an eye roll.
That's still evidence.
It doesn't mean it's
evidence of the Resurrection,
but it does mean that there's
more historicity to the faith
accounts than we had suspected.
And so it would be good to see
these things in conversation.
I was thinking about Richard's
points about the ways
that paradigms can
be de-stabilized.
There's a site at Gobekli
Tepe, which has been excavated.
It's 11,000 years old.
Heinrich Schmidt excavated
it, one of many tepes.
But he actually dug into
it about 15 or 20 years ago
and discovered that it
contained 18 concentric layers
of enormous stone circles
with anthropomorphic and
theriomorphic figures on it.
These are 20 feet high,
they're megaliths,
they were extremely
difficult to build.
We know from incisions in the
rocks around that they were
made and carried great lengths.
The only problem is that they
were made by hunter-gatherers
and set up at enormous
cost and effort, which
upends the Marxist
narrative that you have
to have subsistence and at
least some mode of security
and guarantee of food
and freedom from attack
before you can have religion.
And this upended that narrative.
So it doesn't mean that religion
is true or science is true.
It just means we have
got to think about it
in more complicated ways.
I wanted just to allow
people to pose questions.
And I'm going to
start with Homi,
and then we'll ask you
to pose your questions.
So thank you very much.
I found this to be so
engaging because it
is such an intersective
conversation with convergences
and departures in
important ways.
But one of the
issues that I thought
might be addressed
across the panel,
but found no direct engagement
is the question of desire.
The question of desire--
and I think where I
would root it would
be in Kimberley's attack--
Kimberley, hang on, just
hang on for a second--
on intentionality.
I come in peace.
On intentionality, or the
questioning of intentionality.
And once you begin to question
that, then I think in many ways
the question of desire, not
simply reproductive or sexual,
but the question of
desire, the desire which
starts in the Genesis
story, the unboundedness,
the uncontrolling ability, the
disobedience, the temptation,
the transgression.
and in the Darwin account,
this agonizing, somehow
to keep God out, the
agony of the text
produces a symptomatic desire.
There's a symptom
being written in that.
And I just thought that
this is a concept that,
in terms of art,
for instance, even
the manufacture of
materials to desire,
to move from what is real,
and may not be to realism,
and creates that desire
in the work itself.
So I was just interested,
maybe this question
goes nowhere, leave
it out, but I just
kept thinking for each of you
in different ways, the notion
of desire, I wanted--
One easy place to
start is actually
sidestepping, as we've done
for a second, the question
of reproductive desire.
Whether it is or isn't at the
center of this origin story
is simply to quote the strange
moment, the moment of truth,
as it were, the key moment
when the fruit is taken,
the transgression happens.
The lines in the King
James translation at least
are, when the woman saw that
the tree was good for food.
So we have Richard.
And that it was
pleasant to the eyes,
that it was pleasant
to the eyes.
So there's a extremely strange
registering of its beauty.
There's stickers,
little stickers on it.
But it's not only graspable,
but that it's somehow
visually satisfying.
It's beautiful, aesthetic.
And a tree to be desired.
There you are.
A tree to be desired to
make one wise, is the line.
She took the fruit
thereof and did eat,
and gave it to her husband.
So those three things
that are linked here--
that it was food, that it
was visually satisfying.
Beauty, in a way.
Visually beautiful that it was.
And that it had some cognitive
power or to be desired.
So I think that's
very interesting.
But the point you make,
Kimberley, which fascinated me,
was the splitting of God,
the female part goes.
In Jewish mysticism.
And then the male remains.
And the longing for desire
and that perspective.
And I could go on,
but I just find this
fascinating, [INAUDIBLE].
One place where I think
desire is really interesting
is another point that
Kimberley made about--
and this is something
I'm really curious
about-- the absence
of ethics, and almost
a prescription for ethics not
belonging in the space of myth,
or at least not the
kinds of normative ethics
that we are engaged in.
And so I was starting to wonder
about this desire for ethics
that we seem to have in
both evolutionary and
non-evolutionary narratives
in origin stores.
It's not that there's no ethics.
And I think Stephen's
book makes a great case
for some of the
ethics that emerged
from the tale of Adam and Eve.
It's that at another
level there is a place
that I wouldn't say without
ethics, but is beyond ethics.
So that the fruit is beautiful
and the woman desires it.
But who put it there?
God-- God put it there.
And it is especially beautiful
because he made it that way.
And then as Stephen points
out, told them not to eat it.
So it's a booby trapped
fruit, and they do,
and all sorrow breaks loose.
And God himself, even if he
is not this [INAUDIBLE]----
later Jewish mysticism-- loses,
I would argue, his children,
because I think he does carry
Marduk with him, and I think,
so forth.
But he loses these creations
and he's left alone
walking in the garden.
It's heartbreaking.
The liturgies afterwards in
Judaism and Christianity--
and then when we find it
in [INAUDIBLE] in Islamic
tradition--
[INAUDIBLE] yearning
for reunion with God,
how much they miss him.
But if we look at some
mystical writings,
we find God yearning for
humans, that he's very sad.
I see someone.
I think you have the microphone?
I'm just passing it.
You're passing it.
There was someone
in the back, so.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, would you.
And then here's someone here
you can give the microphone
to afterwards.
Please.
I have a question for
Professor Wrangham.
I'm just trying to work
out how Mitochondrial Eve
and Y-chromosome Adam could
be alive in different times.
So it seems to me that one
solution, and the obvious one,
but probably not the likely one,
is that Eve was messing around,
so that she would have had
children with four, six, eight,
who knows how many different
men, who would have carried on.
Another one would be,
no, Mitochondrial Eve
is the wrong person to look at.
There was a Eve who had
children with an Adam.
And all her female
descendants died out,
except for one line 80,000
years later or something.
Could you comment on whether
Adam and Eve would have
been alive at the same time?
Well, as I said, I mean, 100,000
years could separate them.
But I don't think you have to
point too much to Mitochondrial
Eve herself--
her daughters, her
granddaughters, and so on.
I mean, it just
happened that the males
with whom this lineage
were producing babies
were males who themselves were
remarkably diverse in terms
of their origins.
It maybe happened because the
females were moving around
into different areas.
It maybe because the
males were moving around.
But there's nothing
logical that says
the daughters, the
granddaughters,
and the subsequent
descendants of Eve
had to stick to any
particular set of males
they were associated
with at the time
or location of
Mitochondrial Eve.
But wasn't it the male
line, the Y-chromosome Adam,
that was earlier?
Yes, it goes back
earlier, exactly.
Possibly.
Well, yes.
It could intersect at one point.
That's true.
Yes, I mean, there's
still a range
of error estimates on the dates.
Intersect exactly, so
intersect at one point.
It could at one point.
There's just one point.
It is possible that
they can be united.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, please.
I'd like to ask about some
ethical aspect of the Genesis
story.
So, as I know, Adam
and Eve suddenly
recognized their shame
when they're being nude
after eating the apple.
So I'm wondering, is there
such a shame on nudity?
Being nude, is it
common in all people,
including primitive times?
And if so, is there such a
story about feeling shame
on nudity in other myths
or other [INAUDIBLE]..
Yes.
Yes, I think this
is also a question
that Stephen and
Richard could speak to,
but part of what
was so upsetting
to Europeans in the early
modern era, and even to Darwin
when he visited
South America, was
that he saw people with really
different conceptions of shame
from his own.
He saw people who went
about pretty much naked.
So that form of shame was
not, in fact, universal.
Right.
Yes.
So is there a people feeling
no shame totally nude,
or they have some
minimal [INAUDIBLE] on?
Yeah, there are.
Well, yes.
I think so.
I'm pretty darn sure.
I'm racking my brain
for photographs.
It reminds me-- this
issue-- of Chagnon's story
about the Yanomami
in Venezuela where
the men wear a string that is
tied to the top of the penis,
and it holds the penis
up near to their waist.
And a man would not be seen
dead without his penis string.
But it covers nothing.
It's totally symbolic.
And so what happens is
with missionary histories,
particular Christian
missionary histories,
is that ideas of shame
that are drawn from Genesis
are then imposed on
other peoples who have,
as Richard said, very, very
different cultural notions
of dress, of shame,
very different.
And it becomes extremely
difficult to understand those
because they're coming
out of the story.
I mean, it's possible.
There's other questions, so
let's pass the microphone
around.
I almost hate to bring this
up, but the story of Lilith.
Did you pay any attention
to that in your book?
That is so far afield.
I mean, I mentioned Lilith and
discussed her briefly, but not
a lot of time.
But I think it's a fantastically
interesting story, precisely
because it takes to
a more extreme point
the question of dominance
and disobedience.
The Lilith stories, I'm sure
you know, it's not biblical,
but about a possible, and there
are many speculations about
this-- and rabbinical
speculations--
about possible alternative or
earlier attempts on God's part
to do something--
in this case, an
extra-rabbinical a possible
creation of a female who refused
to obey, and in this case
gave up.
I mean, was threatened
with dire punishments,
including the killing
of her offspring
and nonetheless
refused because she
said she was made of the same
or better stuff from Adam.
The reason I don't
talk about it,
not simply out of
ignorance, but partly
because what fascinated me
is that the biblical story
already, even though it has
this enormously long history
of misogyny associated with it,
has the counter-argument also
built into it, that what
surfaces in the Lilith story
is already what looks
like a much more orthodox
and conventional story of Eve.
There are many people who say
from very early on that Eve
is the hero of the story, that
the disobedience is correct,
that Eve is superior to
Adam because she was created
by the flesh and not
dirt, and because she
was created in the garden
and not out of the garden.
And that is to say, one of the
strange, fascinating things
about the story-- and
it goes back to issues
that Kimberley also
raised-- is that I
don't think it's a mark of
a difference between myth
and literature.
But I think it is
the mark of what
is interesting in both
myth and literature, which
is the possibility of an
alternative interpretation
built into what looks
like a closed system.
And the Adam and Eve
story is astonishing to me
because in a tiny compass,
50 or 75 verses, you have--
Alternative interpretations.
Violently alternative
interpretations
that are hidden inside,
including Lilith, strangely
enough, built into
a story that looks
like it's a clue excluding her.
Yeah, please.
I have a question
about language.
You brought up language.
And in the passage
that you mentioned
when Eve actually gets the
apple, she desires the apple,
she desires to know
and to know beauty.
We imagine that this
happens through language.
And yet, in the later
iterations of the story,
there was a huge question
in the Middle Ages
and in the early modern
period whether the first word
was actually uttered
in paradise or outside.
And Dante actually
leaves it open.
He says in the De
vulgari, he says
the first word was uttered
either inside or outside
the paradise.
So it's a very interesting,
complicated question
about the relationship
between language and knowledge
and beauty and aesthetics
and desire, perhaps, also.
And I wonder whether
you could speak to that?
I mean, there is, as
you know, as well as I,
there's an enormous history
of painting in which there
are gestures, in
which all of this
is acted out without
language at all,
but with bafflement,
head scratching,
or sexual temptation,
the variety of things
that don't necessarily
involve language at all.
It is the case that the
tradition that thinks
that the words existed already.
In
There are interpretations
of the story that
imagine that not
only did, of course,
as Adam gives the
names to the animals
and imagines it as
linguistic-giving,
but also imagines that
Adam had written already
a great philosophical
encyclopedia
about the world, because one
strong line of interpretation
is that humans lost knowledge.
Humans once possessed
more knowledge
and lost it then,
so that Adam must
have had a much fuller
linguistic capacity.
And that this goes
against precisely
the alternative theory.
I don't know enough about the
innumerable alternative origin
stories to know if the
issue of language comes up.
It does in interesting ways.
And one thing, just to
note, is that the Jewish
and the Christian and the
Islamic cosmogonic story
is not the only one
where the gods create
the Earth through language.
And so Genesis is very
startling in that way--
God says, he says the world into
being, he speaks it into being.
And this is the case in
the Popol Vuh, as well,
the Mayan creation cosmogony.
So of course that's picked up--
and I think you mentioned
this-- with the Christian notion
of the logos, the
words that creates
at the beginning of time.
So we even see these
interesting icons
where you find Jesus Christ
walking in the Garden of Eden
as the Logos, as God.
I mean, that's a very common
icon in the orthodox tradition,
as well.
But yeah, the role of
language is not uniformly
stressed, or even mentioned
in some cosmogonies.
My point is it's not
seen in all cosmogonies
as the primary crowning
achievement of creation
or of human life.
It's really interesting to
work in a preliterate dig
where there was no
written history,
but there had to
have been language.
And to know that histories
were being told and shared,
and yet not in a way
that we could have access
to through written
records, but had
to begin to infer through other
forms of symbolic thought,
like hand paintings and
architectural arrangements
and the use of wild animal parts
inside houses, and burials,
and so forth.
Is it believed, Richard, now
that chimpanzees possess some--
Language?
Something that approaches or--
No.
What chimpanzees do is a
relatively sophisticated form
of animal communication,
but it doesn't
have anything like the
symbolic strength of humans.
So you can bring chimpanzees
up to use hand signs,
and they could end up
using maybe a few hundred.
They can combine them into
two or three word chunks.
A tweet, in effect.
Sorry?
Yeah, exactly, yes,
yes, the original tweet.
But it's still
enormously simple.
And so if we're
talking about language,
I think that there is a very
strong case that only Homo
sapiens has had language.
The Neanderthals, for all
of their cultural creativity
in a number of
ways, and they were
able to do almost everything
that Homo sapiens did,
but they did it at
incredibly low rates.
And a predominant
interpretation is
that the big difference
between sapiens
and our Neanderthal companions
was that they had no language.
It's special to us.
Yes?
I'm over here.
I want to first thank you
for a fascinating discussion.
I wanted to turn
to the part of it
where you were all commenting
on the time period from Darwin
after, where there is this
sense of maybe disappointment
or loss or difficulty in
reconciling views of the past
that have a god in them,
and views of the past that
have science in them.
And if you think of
two groups of people
moving along different
tracks and thinking
about the tension
between those groups
that we sometimes see
the results of now.
But that doesn't
necessarily have
to be so because there is an
interpolation about our origin,
but that can co-exist,
right, that difference
an interpolation.
It's where differences
in extrapolation
about what our
origin implies, that
seems to be the cause
of more of the tension.
So I'm wondering if
any or all of you
have thought about whether it's
necessary that interpolating
back leads to the results
of extrapolating forward
that appear to diverge and
creates such problems for us.
That's such a great
way of putting it.
Could you say more about the
issue of what it implies?
How do you see it?
Well, one tends to think about
these days about legislation
that seems to reflect
strong religious beliefs.
And those religious beliefs
correlate with strong views
about literalism.
In terms of interpretation
of religious texts.
And so to me, the tension
of the two streams
plays out in a vision
of society that,
at least on the edges of
those things, seems to differ
Yeah, I mean, I don't mean to
split hairs, but I would say,
perhaps a certain
strand of interpretation
of religious texts.
For example, the
Quran says, if God
had wanted to make just one
religion, he would have.
And there are many other strands
within religious traditions
that are--
I don't want to use the word
tolerant because it sounds
like poison and I wish
we'd get rid of it--
but that are
egalitarian, for example,
or not seeking to discriminate,
to divide, to elevate,
to be hierarchical,
but the opposite.
So I just wanted
to make that point
that we're talking about
interpretive strands.
Right, and I didn't
mean to imply tolerance.
No, no, I know you didn't.
No, I know you didn't.
It's just the sense of, can't
we get people into a room
and try and all get along.
But we don't have to
interpolate the same way.
We can coexist believing
very different things.
Apparently not.
Extrapolation.
But not, though.
But so not.
What is happening?
And I love your question.
And a part of me wonders, you
refer to the time after Darwin.
And even while Darwin himself
was very retiring and really
reticent about this, some of
the proponents of his theory
actually staged conflict The
really famous conversation
between Thomas Huxley and Bishop
Samuel Wilberforce at Oxford
at the British Association
for the Advancement of Science
meeting, which is the one where
Wilberforce said something
like, on which side are you
descended from a monkey.
The whole monkey-human
business was nowhere
in Darwin's writing,
but this was a great way
to publicize these issues.
Right.
And there was a group of
progressive theologians
in the Church of
England who published
a set of essays that accepted
transmutationary kinds
of theories.
Other parts of the Church
of England went haywire.
It depends on your
interpretation.
So I'm wondering,
and I genuinely
don't know this, if
that kind of a start,
if the theory getting off
to that kind of a start
laid the groundwork
for the conflicts
that you're describing
in contemporary stakes.
I mean, again, not to push us
where we can't live together,
but isn't it the case that you,
Richard, as a primatologist,
are not, how shall we say,
only happen to be interested
in a particular animal,
namely chimpanzees,
that you know a great
deal about, but are
interested in the
relationship of chimpanzees
to human origins.
And the kinds of questions that
you ask about from your study,
what are the origins of human
violence and warfare, or how
did humans acquire
the brains that
enable us to process
the things that we do--
those questions, I won't
say are religious questions,
but they're not on
parallel tracks.
I think it's extremely
difficult to keep there
from being some
kind of collusion.
Well, I'm bound to
agree, I must say.
It came home for me
in practice in 2009,
which was the 200th
anniversary of Darwin's death.
And the British Council
held a meeting in Egypt,
hoping to have some kind
of synthesis of thought
with Islamic scholars.
And I would say the email chain
went on for months afterwards
with anyone from an
Islamic country objecting
to the notion of
evolutionary theory.
It was impossible to find
any kind of resolution.
And I think it's right,
there really is a clash.
I mean, for me, as a classic,
boring, old materialist,
I think that what
evolutionary theory has done
is given us a really wonderful
story of human origins that
reduces God to a personification
of the interests of the people
who purvey the story of God.
And it's a really fascinating
use of myth and story
in terms of its
social consequences,
but it's not a
story about origins.
Richard, I have many Muslim
friends throughout the world.
I don't know one who doesn't
accept evolutionary theory.
So perhaps it was
the ones that were
drawn into that
particular discussion.
No, I just mean I
think we have to be
really careful about assuming
that this dichotomy is
universal.
I want to ask both
of you, if I could,
it's something I've
always been dying
to ask evolutionary biologists.
If we were, say, beavers,
and we were building
dams in the shape
of the Taj Mahal
or the Western
Wall or the Vatican
or the Pyramids of
Teotihuacan, wouldn't
evolutionary biologists
be interested in those?
But because of human
exceptionalism,
there doesn't seem to
be a really powerful
and robust and multivalent
exploration of religion,
religious structures,
as part of evolution.
Since we agree we're animals,
we're evolved primates,
we're interested in wasp
nests and beaver dams,
but we are not
interested in religion
as an evolutionary entity,
other than the more basic,
simplistic theories that say,
oh, it's a coping mechanism,
or it's say a form
of social cohesion.
I always want to say, say more.
What else can you say about it?
I'm not trying to put you on the
spot, but I'm just wondering.
You introduce me to
your Islamic scholars.
I'll introduce you to all
the religious scholars
in evolution.
It's a big area.
There's tremendous
excitement about exploring
all sorts of ideas about the
multiple functions of religion.
Within an evolutionary
framework,
since we're primates.
Absolutely.
OK, that would be great.
Because I don't hear that,
I hear them carefully
patrolled and
separated and, yeah,
human exceptionalism becomes
exhausting, in a way.
Oh, well, sorry.
It is restricted to
an analysis of human.
Yes, yes, yes.
But I mean--
Because primates don't do it.
Well, I think Jane
Goodall might disagree.
No, I don't think so.
OK, well, I've
interviewed her on it.
But that's OK, we'll talk later.
I know what you're
thinking about.
No, I'm not.
We'll talk later.
Because chimpanzees throw rocks
under waterfalls and people
have said, maybe these
waterfall displays
are worshipping
nature in some way.
She said that, so let's
stick to the Taj Mahal.
So you're saying that
those monuments and forms
of religious thought,
et cetera, are
being thought about
evolutionarily, as far as what
they do for us, for example.
Yes.
OK, that's great.
I think on this note of
simultaneous disagreement
and concord might be
an appropriate time
to thank you all, and
thank my fellow panelists.
[APPLAUDING]